HANSOL: She's our TA.
TAs know everything.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LINA: Something bad happened.
My flask tipped over.
Something bad always happens
whenever I do an experiment.
It's either my flask tips over
or something explodes.
Do you make mistakes too?
PHIL: I still make mistakes.
LINA: Wait really?
What did you do?
PHIL: What did I do?
LINA: Yeah.
PHIL: I've had some
pretty bad days.
KATHARINA RIBBECK: My
worst day in lab...
JUSTIN BULLOCK:It's more like
a worse like two weeks.
GRACE YAO: My worst day in lab
had to be the day where I had
to smash fish.
PHIL: One day in undergrad, I
was re-crystallizing something
on a hotplate.
NICOLE KAVANAUGH: I was doing
an RNA purification.
GRACE YAO: First of all, I'm
a little scared of fish.
I had this mortar and pestle.
PHIL: I set up this big huge
two liter flask on a ring
stand and everything
connected to a hose
GRACE YAO: And I had to put the
little fish in and smash
it to powder.
The fish head just flew
off onto the floor
PHIL: And before I could fasten
it, the hose whipped
the flask across the room and
it shattered all over.
NICOLE KAVANAUGH: And I
made some poison gas.
JUSTIN BULLOCK: By the end, I
pretty much had nothing left
and it was just a failure.
PHIL: You're going to
cry at that point.
Your day cannot get any
worse than that.
ALONA BIRJINIUK: The very
first time it's always
nerve-wracking.
This is your experiment.
And if things don't go right-
BEN OFORI-OKAI: There are going
to be times where you
may not feel like your
going to be capable.
But the truth is that
you actually are.
You just have to like step
back, take a deep breath,
remember like who you are
like where you came.
KATHARINA RIBBECK: You have
failures of course.
And you're very disappointed
and then redo it.
But this is local and then
you have to move on.
LINA: Something bad always
happens and I always have to
start over.
But Tengfei told me that when
she was an undergrad she was
even worse than I was
and look at her now.
She's teaching us how to
do all these things.
It's so encouraging because
if she can learn,
then I can learn too.
And someday I'll be just
as good as she is.
PHIL: Oh wow, I really should've
been wearing safety
glasses here.